this summer the buzziest drinks are
actually the ones that won't give you a
buzz according to the delivery service
drizzly sales of non-alcoholic beers
wines and spirits are up at least 30
percent over last year epicurious
digital director maggie hoffman has been
covering the trend she and her team made
a list of 23 non-alcoholic drink recipes
that you can make at home and she
brought along a few of them for us to
taste right here on the show maggie
hoffman good morning welcome thanks for
having me so what's been fueling the
rise of non-alcoholic drinks you know i
think this has really been going on a
while uh really creative bartenders even
before the pandemic we're starting to
think okay what can we welcome people
with in our restaurants and our bars
that's better than just you can have a
diet coke you can have a lemonade and so
really creative drinks started appearing
on menus and you know i think during the
pandemic people have been thinking a lot
about wellness and balance and whether
drinks fit in their lives whether they
might want to take a break more and more
people are doing dry january and
reevaluating their relationship with
alcohol so people often refer to these
as mocktails but you say that we
shouldn't use that term don't call them
mocktails yeah you know it's we're not
mocking anything the whole point of
making a beautiful non-alcoholic drink
is to treat yourself to something nice
to welcome guests to your dinner party
uh and so they're real drinks you know
there's a bunch of of new books on the
topic um julia bainbridge has a book of
non-alcoholic drink recipes and it's
just called good drinks for whenever
you're not drinking for any reason not
not drinking alcohol for any reason uh
and
julia momma say calls them uh
spirit-free bartender in chicago so
thinking about you know these are
balanced drinks that are every bit as
interesting as a cocktail um and you're
welcoming everybody with it and you're
not making fun of them there's no stigma
to not drinking
i've actually even seen sorry drink it
but i've actually seen a um
a liquor store you're ready to get to
the
uh a drinks
a a a a store that sells only
non-alcoholic like spirits oh wow it's
called blasto i saw it on the upper west
side of new york city and it's got like
gin and whiskey but but not
an alcoholic
yeah there are so many new products on
the market even between when i was
writing batch cocktails my second book
in 2018 there was maybe one option in
non-alcoholic spirits and now there's
whole stores full all through the
country and the good thing is because
there's not alcohol in them those things
can also be shipped
so let's get to the drinks yeah let's do
that
i'm talking about jericho we got some
pina colada yeah we've got all kinds of
great drinks there's a collection of
recipes on epicurious as you can find
them all there and this is sort of a
range that will demonstrate a little bit
of what's going on okay uh so this is a
not a colada this is a not a collage
it's not a colada we're going with this
one first yeah i don't need this straw
right i
finally i will drink from the straw nate
this is very good so this is a drink
from derek brown and you know wow you
could make a non-alcoholic pina colada
with justice
that is good you finished the whole
thing
you downed it
there's no alcohol in it okay sure that
is so so it's tasty make this with just
pineapple and coconut cream but then it
wouldn't be that interesting
and he puts a few secret ingredients in
there to make it taste a little more
complex a little more like the rum
version that tastes better than a normal
pina colada it's very good it really
does you drink it in the morning all
right what else do we have over here so
this other one is from my book batch
cocktails the recipe is also on
epicurious uh
smells really good
what's it called it's called the
blaylock the blaila and it's so simple
you can make this at home have you ever
had a grapefruit and put honey on it or
put sugar on it and the flavor comes out
yeah this is just fresh grapefruit
lemon juice honey
if you want you can toast the little
spice that you put on top but you don't
have to and that's something that you
can make in a big picture and have ready
for a brunch or a barbecue if anyone
wants to slow down anyone's taking the
man just already downed it oh my god
well that's what we're supposed to do
that's the point of the segment you're
supposed to drink them you're over
you're sipping like i am sipping on it
i'm sipping them like wow you know
feeling good we got we got one more we
got a spritz right yes
last one is really a celebration of
what's out there now
you can get great non-alcoholic wine now
this is a non-alcoholic reasoning from
lights called einstein zero
um
it almost has a taste like a little bit
a little bitter a little bit of wine so
this and it has a non-alcoholic aperitif
called wilfrid's but there's a huge
range of these available now
frank the tank frank the tank frank
oh my god man he really did finish wow
it touches your lips this is delicious
so good once it hits the lips maggie
hoffman
thank you so much they are really good
my favorite is the natta colada though
yeah the colada is really good and it
has a lot of flavor and it's layered
temples that's what everybody knows
the new generation of non-alcoholic
drinks just don't want to go outside i
want to sit in something like this with
this drink take the rest of the day all
right i think i need another maggie
you're the best
top me off again baby if you want some
of these drinks we have the recipes just
visit our cbs morning's facebook and
twitter pages to find all of these
recipes we will be right back
you don't even have that shirt
cheers
thank you thank you thank you